the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and it's using us
instead of us using it
but with the adan app you can use it in
perfect alignment with your life the
adan app is already used by 40 million
believers around the world why because
it caters to your islamic lifestyle on
top of this a lot of times you get your
eyes vikkar the islamic calendar ramadan
calendar suhur and iftar times
hajj and umrah guide
and much more for free so download the
addon up now
we just finished recording the episode
and i can firmly say if your discretion
is advised if you're not of age
especially if you're not married
are going to be married soon do not
watch this video um your discretion
advice once again assalamu alaikum
welcome back to another episode of
salafi tea time insha allah we are going
to begin this episode and i'm just
playing bro three muslims real realized
pakistan
we got a very special guest once again
brother gabriel arumani
bro like that
maybe i don't know if you guys want that
let us know in the comments hashtag
selfie tea time if we get a thousand
likes on this video inshallah we'll
consider it yes but uh we got sheikh
holnica again for a very special episode
on secrets to a spicy intimate life with
your wife or wife
not your wife
just
grammatically
but
all right let's get it though
is
okay
well as a counselor i'm sure you deal
with a lot of marital issues marital
cases
uh extramarital stuff too i'm assuming
right what is one of the most common
actually you know what let's take it
back a bit because everyone's like why
are you guys always talking about sex
why are you guys always talking intimacy
so are we always talking about it yeah
bro according to them bro so what is the
importance of it like why are we even
talking about this in the first place
alhamdulillah
which is a verse but it's also
him
so
it's also a
an evidence or a miracle
right so from among these miracles that
he created from yourselves wives
and he has put between you
love and mercy
right
so also says first love
and then mercy
love is there is the driving force is
the the energy that creates life subhan
allah
you know what i mean i mean of course by
the blessings of allah
but it is the energy that creates life
so by default making love
i mean that's how you create life isn't
it yeah obviously
again going back to the 21st century we
talked about this before today
and i'm going to try to use
the term making love as much as i can
this in this session inshallah and you
can see how the term changes your
perception on things
if you were to say sex
or
smashing smashing or
something more people think a bit right
it's like dirty and
okay it has a place in your relationship
we'll talk about that
but you see already people you're like
oh because
today it is something that everyone's
concerned with no doubt about it yeah
yet of course a lot of people due to
what's happened in society media
they kind of feel like it's something
dirty taboo we shouldn't be talking
about it
yeah
why are we talking about it is because
it is the main
driving force in a marriage
making love
because you're making love you love each
other
a man and a woman loving each other
and building that love
that relationship through the act of
intimacy
a man and woman connecting to that deep
level
where not only their body become one
but like their souls pretty much
get close their hearts
like look just physically speaking you
know the hearts get together
emotions flow
the way if you
analyze how the body reacts during
intimacy they're making love
the hormones that are released
what happens in the body just it's
nothing short of a miracle man
and allah says
and from his miracles
all right
and not to mention
that the main objective
other than uniting and enjoying each
other in halal you've waited your whole
life you've protected yourself
what we call afafa chastity
you've protected yourself your whole
life you've
you know held yourself you've lowered
your gaze you've tried hard to obey
allah
and now you're finally
allowed to
enjoy yes enjoy
but putting aside the element of
enjoyment
by the will of allah that act of making
love
creates life man
right supply you
impregnate your wife
and she has a baby your baby
and then you build a family and there's
more love
that
is nurtured through that family now it's
not just husband and wife loving each
other but now you have another
object of love which is your child or
two or three or four or five subhanallah
and more love gets generated
and we're talking about it
because in our counseling
sessions in our experience
we find that this element is missing or
it's
somehow
not done properly
people don't understand it and a lot of
it has to do with what we said either
media
distortion of its name or of its essence
and
many other elements in today's society
that
make people to fail in the most
basic important elements of this
union of marriage of the relationship
what i mean so that's what we're talking
about we want people to
realize that if your love life
is good
if you
can remove the barriers and connect on
that deep level
then i say always i always say that if
love
life and communication are good
of course by default your taqwa and your
deen has to be you know like we're not
even going to say no
is like number one but if your love life
and communication between husband and
wife are good
i think you can sort any other issue out
in your life
so that's why
so we're not like one of those channels
that's like oh this is how you get women
this is how you get her to home base
this is a trick to keep her infatuated
with you it's not like yeah
bro this is genuinely how to keep it
away
yeah relationships better keep your wife
happy in life in charlotte
i do like the uh change in wordage
it definitely changes the vibe yes you
know like the way that you would make
the way that you were saying it is like
while there's haya in this it's like
yeah it just seems like very natural but
when we say like smashing and
i'm gonna say the other stuff i was just
about to do that
you started listening to you just like
ah you can't even be serious anymore
like it's goofy bro it's not academic
anymore yeah smell i bless you for that
but look um
there's definitely smashing happening
but that's like between you and her
that's in once you establish that
relationship there's going to be a more
um emotional manifestation of that love
sometimes it's going to be more carnal
there's nothing wrong with it i mean
that's the whole issue of shahawat and
desires
and allah has given you
your desires in halal or in desires in
haram
right there's
boundaries like even
when you look at right intimacy making
love also sam only forbade one thing
other than that it's like it's pretty
much open right
there's some limits of course within the
sharia no
but yes there's a time where a husband
and wife are more
just into desire
like literal just physical carnal desire
and sometimes more just emotional and
combined so it's not just one way but
society makes you think like it's just
one way one objective and it's just like
smash it down hammer it down and move on
kind of thing right and it's all about
you
right you just satisfy yourself it's me
myself and i
and whatever it doesn't matter whatever
everyone else does and what any there's
no issues of ethics or morality or
love or passion or emotion it's just
whatever and
i don't know you yeah yeah
i mean it
it's crazy because when you mention like
oh you know a baby comes out of this
life is formed now this it's like it's
almost like it hit me again for the
first time because we're so detached
from that it's like it's not making love
it's just like it's doing whatever it's
pleasing yourself is this very liberal
concept of i need to feel physical
pleasure to feel fulfilled in life it's
like la
you're going to have children in sha
allah like that's such a big thing
nowadays
back in the day it was not so much
anymore unfortunately and bro it's no
wonder that when you type the three
muslims on youtube or gabriel armani
what is one of the first searches that
come up bro intimacy intimacy bro and
that's why we've partnered up with uh
our brother gabriel armani this is not a
joke by the way for a lot of the new
viewers that don't know we've actually
made an intimacy series believe it or
not editor can put it up on the screen i
think we got 50 or 100 or 150 000 views
like total in all the episodes it was
like eight or nine episodes total bro
there's a lot of stuff that went into
that inshallah so this is mainly like
this is kind of like a cliff notes like
a summary for anyone that didn't watch
that or any new viewers it's just like
just to give an introduction of course
inshallah we'll have gabriel in the
future when we get our proper proper
studio in a few months insha allah
and we're going to do a lot of intimacy
stuff for play everything in detail
all the mothers and fathers can tune out
for now inshallah and uh now i'm playing
mothers and fathers need to hear this
yeah they need to tune in what i mean is
my mom and dad
if you're watching this but
anyway without being with that being
said bro i think we have about 30 35
more minutes let's go right in bro so
what are some of the major
problems that you see in couples today
types so with regards to making love and
intimacy
a lot of people are
uneducated
right so as the whole
talk before you get married
what we call sex ed
so you have society today
you have giving sex out to children like
the age of like what like seven or six i
was looking at the curriculum
um i think southwest uh wales or
irish curriculum
someone sent me a document and i was
looking i was like you guys are teaching
this like
seven years old and six-year-old some
people don't even get taught
that's
[Music]
you have to be thought but not not that
way now it's better to be not taught
than inappropriately inappropriate time
i mean it's it is inappropriate i mean i
like that yeah and
if you look at it i mean first time they
opened up that subject with us in
in school was grade nine were like
already 14. it was a bit late because
we're just laughing what a joke you know
and all i remember was oh masturbation's
healthy you guys need to explore
yourself that's all i got ridiculous
so i think parents this is parents
responsibility
if it is educators
i mean within our paradigm of islamic
schools and so on it should be done in
collaboration with parents like that
part of the curriculum has to be agreed
upon
it has to be all stakeholders in a
child's life should be somehow you know
involved the main ones in your parents
and
educators because it's such a sensitive
thing
it is so primal it's so deep it's so
important that if you teach them
the wrong thing it's very hard to undo
because it stimulates the the most inner
desires
so we find for example
children who are exposed to
certain sexual
acts
at a young age the age of seven
six and it happens as young as that
they
stumble upon a porn stash of their
parents
which a lot of people understand
they have even some of the most
conservative people will have this which
is wrong man you know this is totally
totally wrong because
this guy or this girl stumbles upon the
stash
watches it okay
and
all of a sudden their whole
the first experience they've ever had
with intimacy
is that
and it's very difficult to remove that
from your mind it's literally your it's
imprinted in the back of your mind
and you might not even realize your body
changes your
mind your brain changes
and what happens is
it's a trauma
it is it is a trump
and with trauma
especially that's
so
related to your instincts
what you're going to want to do first
you're going to be shocked you're not
going to know how you're what why your
body is reacting away and yes even at an
age you can experience pleasure
confusion
and what do you want to do you want to
get more
you want to understand more first you're
going to be scared
going to pull back and
next you want to get more
so now you start exploring
and no one's no one knows no one's
telling you stop and you explore more
and more and your
concept of the true
pure form of love is now distorted
and i could say that majority of people
go through this i mean subhana i don't
know if i've ever dealt with anyone who
has said no no i'm just i've never seen
these things i just grew up
i mean i'm sure they are but we haven't
obvious people come to us
somehow whether it's in the back of the
class some boy comes look at this man
look at this magazine back in the days
right boys will be coming look at this
magazine yo now it's like look at my
phone
right
i'm just whatsapping telegramming videos
sharing links forget about you know look
it's so easy before you know teacher
will come smack you take it away talk to
your parents whatever and i was just
like you know saying i want to ask you
like why is this happening though
because i know in the daisy community
there's a lot of arab households there's
this taboo
you know vibe with intimacy like parents
don't like talking about it because you
got to realize and and i know i know
you're going to get into this but in
islam there's no necessarily this
restriction in talking about intimacy
with the kids you see the prophet sallam
you see the sabbah everyone was very
open with this topic you know what i
mean okay i think in the west there's
there's this whole like let's not talk
about it right it's awkward and you
before you know you have stuff like
epstein's islands and you look at the
christianity wrote the priests and the
kids in church bro like we're very open
as muslims right is that is that true or
not we should be well i think open like
we need to define that word right
transparent with our kids
okay i think the west is very open to
open so you have that balance the
western non-muslims
right today's society and then as a
reaction
the muslims in the west and in muslim
countries they're kind of like oh my god
you know i don't want my kids to to know
this
um
like okay i'll might be engaging in
myself or whatever but i don't want my
kids
to know this it's like kind of like the
parent smokes but you know if he catches
his son smoking smack you know why
smoking hot
right it's like we have this i think
it's it's a good intention
it's an intention of trying to protect
the child because without action yeah
the ch the parents realize that this can
really disturb my child because it's
probably disturbed them
so they try to protect them but in doing
so it's not about
screening your child away from something
that is
just primal
you want to screen your child from
yes pornography and what's around all
the distortions
but you want to have some form of guided
exposure or education
to the subject at the right time now
when is the right time it depends
okay it depends a parent has to be aware
and observe the development of their
child
i mean that's why they're shocked
because they're never engaged in their
development they don't realize that oh
wait a second they kind of just wake up
like oh my god he's already 13 and i've
never had the talk with him
by 13 trust me the talk there's no need
for a talk he's already done his
research or his peers already educated
him in the wrong sense
so what happens now
this child has these uh preconceived
ideas about
he's not making love anymore he doesn't
want to make it he wants to smash it
all right so he takes that and he that
keeps being conditioned parents become
even more shy let's say there's a
discussion
why would the child be like mom don't
talk to me while still you know
right or something and uh
the parents get all like they don't know
parents come to us parents come to
teachers like when should i have the
talk can i have the talk can you have
the talk i'm like i'm gonna talk to them
you know i might give a lecture about it
but
it is
it is sensitive
so most people don't want to be in a
sensitive situation they just pull away
they say well you know i'll make the
offer or something like that let's see
what happens and most children boys and
girls have sexual experiences as early
as seven
be it pornography be it masturbation
be it
uh even i mean there's a lot of abuse a
lot of the first introduction to
intimacy is through abuse and most of
the time it's from very close family
members
cousins even audibly you know very real
you know like brothers and sisters man
like we have so many weird
cases
and imagine
you when you dig deep into it that
person was
doing the abuse
have had a distorted image of intimacy
and because they don't know how to
control those feelings and emotions no
one to talk to they want to express
those emotions they're going to do it in
that way that they've been educated
which is wrong towards that child
so like i was talking to one of the
clients and
they're saying that
so her cousin did something to her
and he was a bit older than her right
imagine she's six bro
six
so he's done something like stuff like
penetrated at that age bro
right she was like he took my virginity
at the age of six
so
she said i thought
like she didn't know how to feed how
what she feels and but she said i
thought this is like love
and he told me that he loves me
and my parents didn't tell me that i
love me so i felt very attracted to that
but then i would do the same thing to my
neighbors
girls and boys and one day he caught me
like he walked in on me and i was with a
girl neighbor so
like a little kid yeah so she's six and
the other girl was like whatever same
five or six and they're doing stuff
and
the guy saw her and he's like what are
you doing
this is haram you're the one that calls
them right and
like imagine he's like she said he sat
me down and told me like it's not
allowed this is not good and she
basically said
but this is what you taught me like you
said it's love and i he said she's my
best friend i love her
so i want to express my love towards her
because that's what he taught me
so imagine this
butterfly effect almost in this chain of
reactions that happens
that girl might be going to her class
later on at the age of seven or eight
like kind of what happened in one of my
schools and the whole class was
corrupted
right and like come let me show you
something or hey let's you know let me
show you something
and the other one let me show you
something it just spreads
and then within 10 years like you got a
whole community corrupted
and the parents are still saying like oh
no
be careful don't talk about this let's
not talk about this you know shyness
there's a difference between
having haya
about something and educating and the
process himself like if you're like
you're not going to learn if you're too
shy if you're not willing to ask now
we have to find a balance and we want to
be as academic as possible i know
someone's joke and whatnot but it's a
very serious issue that needs to be
addressed and solved
right
and
you
yes
yeah
respect and so on but we have to educate
and um
like we can't be talking just
openly about weird stuff and whatnot
just being very rude that's what the
non-muslims do right and that's where
the muslims like oh my god i don't want
my kids to know that they already know
that but you have to educate them you
have to tell them you have to express
the process tell them for example
one of the first
more descriptive incidents when it comes
to intimacy
is when they migrate to medina
and there was a different culture when
it comes to intimacy in terms of
positions for example yeah so the
sabbahs were a bit they were marrying
women from medina very different culture
they wanted to have intimacy in a
different way so the sabbaths were
asking from a perspective of is it
permissible to do it like this or to do
it like that so we find that they're
going through the process of selling and
getting educated
when it comes to intimacy
so what's the process himself you know
he didn't say stuff allah you know
should not be talking about this
no
they was always education we see also
for young younger girls for example
getting married
the females in the community were
preparing her sometimes for three four
days
in terms of just talking to her and just
getting her ready you know getting her
beautified and so on and telling her
stuff and it was not something like i
have no clue what i'm doing i'm going
you know in this and you're like
what am i supposed to do
right
so there was education
that's what i would like to see i mean
don't have to go in too many details but
there was education with respect with
hayah at the time of rasulallah we need
to do that with our children
as i said parents and
schools together in a joint effort
guided exposure
within the halal to
understand mothers to talk to their
daughters to be close to them so that
they can
open up to them and talk about these
things
you know does your daughter come and say
well i have a crush or i like this or i
feel like this or some
daughters don't even know what a period
is man they get scared the first time
they get their period
you know you're bleeding from down there
right
it's it's a very
terrifying and
traumatizing event
a mother should tell them this this [ __ ]
and it shouldn't be like oh like it's
more of a shame thing don't tell your
father or come here or whatever no it's
like you should be proud of her that
she'd become a woman
celebrate it to an extent like
you know love her and
and tell her you've now gone through
another level in your life you know what
i mean
and same with with men
yeah look this way
i was gonna
leave killing me i keep looking at this
little piece of limb bro relate to what
you're saying before a lot of people
unfortunately have a very disturbed view
on
sexuality intimacy and all of that so
unfortunately since they have this view
how do they take care of that because we
want to talk about how to have a good
intimate life how do you do that if
you're you know disturbed in that sense
i mean as we started right coming from
that point of being disturbed being
damaged being um traumatized
and
it's almost i mean trauma is difficult
right like how do you come from
having a perverted view of what
intimacy is to bringing it back to
within the halal realms right
so interesting case study
when 50 shades of grey came up the book
forget about the movie you know the book
i mean the muslim community was in
crisis
but it was probably the first time
that and i was i was i think very i was
i was a social worker at that time in
our community and i know there was a lot
of divorce and problems because husbands
were catching the wives reading that
book
it was the first time i would say within
the muslim community
western muslim community probably
eastern as well
where like female sexuality was like
coming out you know like people were
like what i don't recognize
it was a problem because again people
are not educated right there's a false
there's a false party yeah you have to
have haya but does that mean that you
can overprice good
intimacy with your wife now 50 shades of
grey is a whole different thing but what
it shows
and we can discuss about the whole
bondage and you know being rough and
whatnot but what's uh what it exposed is
that there's a lot of suppressed desire
greeks and females now don't think that
it was just from their fitrah
these women were already
going and conditioned through society
and all of a sudden this just kind of it
was the chair on top yeah but you know
what this reminds me of the other people
we were talking about what we were
saying how like every woman has that
like
that freak inside them you know we could
say different word if if y'all want to
have some higher here well you said it
was just how no no
hello
yeah right it's a freak it's about their
they have a wild
sexual desire we're human beings yeah
what i'm trying to say is that like it's
it's bringing it back to where
like you you are the one that's in
charge of bringing that out of her but
it's also you who could also
lock that away
and she'll find other avenues like you
know maybe she's like she's starting to
let it out and then you're like yo where
did you learn this
right like you said
like you said another piece so
i like it it's all tying in together
it's just about it's a balance between
bringing her out and and locking it it's
about controlling it right because how
did how did the men respond though with
the full 50 shades thing when it came
out yeah the men were shocked and they
started divorcing their wives really as
opposed to understanding it look
that's the question right so what do you
do when you're in this kind of situation
a a community men and women who have
been conditioned have gone through this
process of being exposed to these
perversions
right and then here you are now face to
face
everything's on the table
how do people react because i can
guarantee you that a lot of those men
themselves have been exposed to these
things
but it's the whole concept of
and misconception that women shouldn't
have desire they don't have desire it's
been popularized by the judeo-christian
tradition for hundreds of years right
the the myth of the female orgasm and so
many parents there's just so much that's
been happening
and it definitely friends the muslim
community
so now finally something comes out
shocked like people like oh i don't
recognize they're saying i don't
recognize my wife like who is this
person like is this really there and of
course like where did you even get to
that point i totally believe though i've
always said this i believe had there
been no porn
no social media none of this conditions
right i think a man and a woman can just
naturally
please each other in a beautiful
innocent
yet very primal primal and and organic
and passionate way
but here we are in the 21st century
everywhere you look
hypersexualization
do this smash that this is big this is
small to go to the store you know
everywhere toys schedules boys gadgets
right
what do you do like how do you deal with
this just
okay that's it what are you gonna
divorce every woman because i would tell
you that
literally from our cases even women from
the village are being exposed man forget
it bro it's done i mean it's like all
men if not you know i'm not one i don't
just generalize but
most men have been exposed or are aware
of these things but you see there's a
double standard like oh how come women
like this guy who's questioning the one
most likely he's
you know has been exposed to this you
said this in in the last episode too
that and then for them they might have a
weird order but in the last episode that
we filmed you were saying that allah has
designed the woman
with an organ or a part body part the
[ __ ]
which is strictly for pleasure there's
no other function
even as men we don't have a specific
body part who has that's specifically
for function for just pleasure we don't
bro we don't and it's it depends how you
look at it you can be like oh my god
it's so nasty or you can be like wow you
know mashallah that's like amazing right
and you can explore that in halal way
and have a beautiful intimate life
within the boundaries of islam islam
puts the boundaries
now people can step outside of
boundaries which we see everywhere right
but why do people step outside because
they don't even know the boundaries
because they don't they're not educated
about they have no clue
and naturally gonna be inclined like
these things are attractive
okay we have to understand the whole
concept of the forbidden tree why in the
end adam and eve still
after being with allah after hearing
from allah after giving a direct order
from allah they still went and did it
right because
these kind of things are attract haram
is attractive
people you know it's it
pushes you
but so within what we're talking about
there's a lot of haram so people are
very very attracted to it especially you
see it everywhere being conditioned
every single day you're being told oh
try this try that and you have this
boring lifestyle where your husband
sleeps with you like
once a month or something or your wife
sleeps with you like once a month
both sides
and you know you start talking to your
girlfriends and your boys and whatever
and people are sharing now experiences
which is not good you should never share
your bedroom experiences like a big
night or when you're going through
details and one nice difference between
educating and just going yeah i did this
to my wife and that people do that and
the guy sitting there
he's his wife didn't give him any for
like a month right and he's like oh man
and he's like don't worry man just go
like a massage place or something you
know you get sorted out or whatever and
the guy's like oh yeah so in his mind
now shaytan is going to come and keep
telling him you know look what this
woman is doing to you she's not sleeping
with you you deserve
and people just go i mean people commit
zina man like there's no tomorrow and if
they don't commit zina they're addicted
to porn and if they don't and they're
not exporting just masturbate like
we're unhealthy and unhealthy society
when it comes to
intimacy
why is that because we're not willing to
have these kind of discussions and to
educate when parents are not willing to
sit down schools are not willing to do
it properly so we leave it to everyone
else for grabs so the school boards and
non-muslim school boards do it youtube
does it pornhub does it everything does
it
and then people wake up and like oh why
is my wife
reading 50 shades of a grape watching
whipping and whatnot right she's a free
right because it's been built that
freak's been built over years and years
and you haven't fed that beast in the
right way with some halal food and now
it's hungry you know what i'm saying
is
man i just think that it's it's actually
beautiful i don't understand why certain
brothers would see this as an issue you
know like we all have fantasies
right men women
so like if
if i'm married and i walk in and i see
that my
my wife is reading 50 shades of gray
like
bring the whips out it's time
abdullah get
[Laughter]
how do you deal with this right so you
could just divorce her and be like this
is bad or you can understand what's
happening bro if i walked in on my wife
and she's reading like a book like that
i'd be like yes finally what do you do
if you're walking on your wife like i
had a client walk to his wife and caught
her watching she's masturbating watching
lesbian porn
wow i mean see the thing is where's the
limit right or like bestiality
this happens or child porn
right and this like again like i had a
client just i mean he's like destroyed
because he's like what the heck is going
on so where again where are the limits
because if you don't know the limits bro
you can just fall into a dark abyss on
on your channel you you you call
yourself real problems real solutions
right so
in an ideal situation i know you just
mentioned you start the kids young you
talk about you know these things openly
and and from a very young age before
they get programmed but the reality is
just like you said everyone's already
conditioned everyone's already
programmed so let's say you're dealing
with a spouse that is already heavily
conditioned or maybe you yourself very
programmed right you have uh you you
made yourself basically have a
conditioning with getting off to
porn or for a woman she has these types
of fantasies or she's made herself a
numb with all these toys or whatever you
know there's a lot of these issues so
what are you doing now with this couple
yeah i mean that's an amazing story
what i can do on that that what they can
do are two different things but before
we get into it i wanted to say that see
the main element that we've talked about
we said is the most important one in
this is the taqwa
because the taqwa is gonna
put those limits
so yes i mean we can talk another
episode as to what's permissible what
can be done but the talk was gonna put
the limits now the mind and the fitra is
gonna want to see what's beyond those
limits i mean this is the reality bro
even for the most
every son of adam will commit sins
meaning you're passing the boundaries of
allah
the mind is going to want to right
especially in this environment but the
taqwa
is what keeps it i believe human beings
the way they being you know the way we
are the way being conditioned like we
can do anything man like
a person by their fitrah if they don't
fear allah as the prophet said
if you have no
shyness you'll do whatever
men and women can do whatever bro but
that's why the main ingredient is taqwa
that's what's going to limit you oh you
want to watch lesbian porn well no stuff
allah i can't even if you're like
inclined towards oh you want to watch i
would be lost something or bestiality or
something weird man you know totally
outside of what's permissible
and people it's just desire it's just a
fantasy a lot of people just say it's
not real
it's different in the mind it's some
things are better just to be kept in the
mind no because you're going to that's
going to be implanted in your mind it's
going to grow into thoughts into action
into plans into actions
that's what
he's like that's what happens start with
that thought just gets in there it
starts growing and they start planning
then it's going to end up and you're
just on a slippery slope
so talk was no i would be like
you know i'm not going to do it i stay
within what is permissible yes it can be
a fitna it can be a struggle but this is
the way the success is and there's a lot
that can be done in there
right
but going back to the question what do
you do
it depends on the people as well
right so
wife walks in a guy another client and
you know 10 years they've been married
and watched catches him watching a
specific type of poor
and she sees that the woman that looks
at is not what she is
and she said why like what he starts
saying i'm not pleased with you i don't
like you why'd you marry me
i can't be that
white girl you know like i'm this
you know and now it makes sense why you
tell me to dye my hair and put you know
whatever context you know green context
i'm not that you're trying to change me
you know and she's traumatized
and she divorces him because she's like
you know you don't like me and the guy
doesn't even fight for him like no it's
okay i do like you let's work at it
it depends on the people as well or
you know one of my clients i mean
his wife was like just
wild bro you know like asking for like
anal sex and all kinds of weird stuff
you know pushing him to weird stuff and
the guy he was a bit more traditional he
couldn't handle that
my advice to him was like look you have
to understand she's a bit sick
you know so you have two choices you
either push a sick person to the curb
outside it's gonna still be sick she's
not gonna be healed you know
or you you deal with it you manage it
and you become more mature
and in how you
address this issue and you can try to
help her to fight her fitna not everyone
can do that because especially
for a man
who is
from his perspective his woman is his
woman
right i think it's weird so and again
not
maybe listening to the fitra women can
sometimes accept a bit more when men
mess about and they'll have more
patience and stick around because they
know it's kind of like in the fit
throughout the man
and
you know the whole like i want more than
one woman
and as long as we can fix it i'll stick
with you
in general
but when a man sees his wife going into
this weird stuff
it's i don't know i feel that most men
are not willing to to to take it on
they're just they basically divorce
their lives they can their their their
and their jealousy
you know i mean
for example one of the couples i was
trying to work with on the brothers i
said look just have patience but it just
it was getting worse and worse the woman
who didn't want to do anything to the
point where she would like be going on
the street and like checking out like oh
look at this guy's thing or look at that
imagine you're saying that to your
husband she can't control herself
right she can't control herself like
doing weird stuff and the guy was just
shocked like wow how do i deal with it
you know he's broken
he's like i you know i'm i'm broken one
other client the way he said he said i
saved my my whole
life
i'm a virgin i'm a virgin man
and then i found my wife that she lied
to me and she's like this
right like how do i
he's like i understand but
i made it clear at the beginning and
that's what i want on this purity and
here i am so how do you deal with this
i feel that
ideally
ideally
people should work at it
yeah if instead of just call our
questions yeah if both are willing to
but in many of these cases as i can say
like one side is not willing to
all right
so you kind of push the
whatever your husband to the curb or
your wife to the curb this is the
conversation you have with them to
decide if they're both willing to or
yeah of course
right but it's not just about that right
so it's about what happens in the next
session you recap and you know for
example the brothers say like yeah we
went to
outside and she's still talking about
the stuff like she's not waiting to
change she keeps saying i'm going to
change i'm going to change
i call i come home i catch her doing
herself
you know like every time i come i have
to take the internet away from from my
home i have to take the miss work i
have to take them
i have to take the modem away man like
imagine you're leaving home you got to
take the more like what he's like i
can't think i can focus on my work
because i'm at work and i'm thinking
what is my wife doing at home
or the other way around right the woman
is whatever and she's you know like in
this you know
yeah bro it's like you know every look
this this one sister said every time i
have an argument with my husband
he takes the phone and runs to the
bathroom and locks himself up and he
does himself
what and i'm he says i'm knocking the
door saying here allah come out i can do
it for you this is haram you know what i
mean haram
imam so she's knocking the door saying
fear allah come out
she's saying like
let's have intimacy let me do a friend
he's like leave me alone and he's like
doing himself maybe that's his coping
mechanism bro because as a kid maybe
that that's it
but there's still responsibility
you can't just blame your trauma so you
have to understand that you have to deal
with it but again you have two
individuals who are both maybe
traumatized coming together they've
never solved that trauma so there's no
education around it they're not even
aware they're not watching the three
muslim podcasts too you know to
understand what's going on
they're just
they've gone through all this they're
they think that somehow once they get
married that's it everything's gonna
work out
and now you're on your night of your
marriage one's doing stunts and the
other one's like clueless what to do
right
and you're like what the heck
you know right and and then then what
happens in next month well one sleeps in
one room and the other one sleeps in on
the right side
they're just embarrassed like what the
heck did we just do what happened
instead of talking but things should
have been done from way before man
people should be educated protected from
these kind of things right
but this is not the case that's why it's
very important for the men and women to
you know both meet each other
in here in this situation that we're
talking about but also very important
for the men to
uh be the leaders that they're meant to
be right because
if if your woman is
going in some sort of direction you have
to be will you have to be able to pour
back and bring her into this direction
and it's not to say like oh no it should
only be super pure all the time and
nothing like you know prime or carnal
because like we said you know this is
gonna be there everyone has fantasies
but it's understanding this you know
meeting at the same place and then going
at it together and understanding even
though you're going at it together you
as the man are the leader
and like if your girl has some fantasies
like that like if you're walking on your
wife and she's
over here watching pornography look like
you set her down and you really talk to
him be like look
like you know that i love you
you know like i care for you i take care
of you i do this like
but this is not good like you know you
know this is not good now
you have fantasies look i get this i
have fantasies
you have sensations i have sensations
but we have to work with what we have
available to us like you said the halal
right so it's
stuff because again where where do you
how do you do it some people can do it
like some people
will
take that approach have that discussion
and continue and literally like
have a mature attitude about it knowing
that as you said you have fantasies i
offend why do we have these fantasies
because we've been bringing condition
into it
i keep saying i know personally man
i'm maybe i'm old school tradition or
whatever
but i still believe in the purity of you
know of lovemaking
right yeah
i i still think if there would be none
of this trash around bro
right men and women could please each
other within a matter of minutes bro
without having all these weird things
and whatnot
that's ideally now what's happening in
reality it's a different story right i'm
not i'm not i'm not absent i know
exactly what's going on and what to do
but i still believe you know in the
purity of the dean bro
i got a question though um
but
you're saying that if someone is not
adultered by
society they will have
like very natural tendencies they won't
have like these crazy fans 100 so you're
telling me if there was like a village
and then you had like married some girl
in the village like
no internet no social media i don't
think she's gonna be thinking about like
getting ravaged by like one of the other
tribesmen or something like that
good question because you could roleplay
you could be like oh like
like you acting like you from the other
tribe and you're coming in
look there's gonna be there's gonna be
desire
but you see these fantasies are
implanted and inseminated through
different things around
it's always there's always a corruption
of the fitra or something like that
right there's always
i'm not saying people are not gonna have
desire or they're gonna see someone
that's attractive and maybe desire them
but it's not going to be to the level of
what we see today bro like you're
talking about some seriously disturbing
things that are happening within the
realm of fantasy
and what happens is that the way it
works on your brain is that now your
your pleasure
threshold is increased so meaning you
need more of that to be pleased
so men and women are not pleased
especially women
right because a lot of times guys have
they don't really know what they're
doing
they don't acknowledge
how complicated the female body is and
female sexuality is how deep it is
there's a lot and on the other side too
some women don't please men
you have tons of men who are saying i'm
not getting enough
and so on usually for women is the
quality
what's the problem usually for men is
the
quantity they're not getting it enough
that's the complaints we we get
so but what i'm saying is that
i forgot but we're sick
but
yeah i mean if it's natural it's
protected it's beautiful
if it's
whatever you let's say you've been
damaged you can still work
yeah that's the question we can still
work with what we have
do people choose to work with what they
have can they have that level of
maturity and that kind of conversation
to understand and to explore okay what's
your fantasies if it's a fantasy is it
permissible to explore it to what level
i mean we can talk about this in maybe
another episode i've had some discussion
with some sheikh about this there are
some
some texts of older scholars from
hundreds of years ago even discussing
these issues
so what's permissible
are you mature enough to discuss it can
you i would say
a lot of people cannot
and i can't blame them like imagine as a
husband
or as a wife you are you have a purity
and then you catch your husband doing
something very strange and weird
are you really responsible be like oh
let me act that out for you like if
you've been
raised in a certain pure way your whole
life and you find that shocking you want
a very pure way and maybe that's what
you're looking for a husband
and maybe you're being deceived in
marrying this person i don't know or the
other way around
can you just blame that person for
wanting to leave
i wouldn't necessarily blame them
like i wouldn't blame someone for
wanting to stay who has the level of
maturity like look
you know what as you said like you have
yours i have mine how about we just talk
a little bit and be mature about it and
save our marriage and maybe we can
define the lines and just remind each
other with allah to stay within those
lines because if not then here's a woman
who's divorced with fantasies and here's
a man who's divorced with fantasies
again alone single what do you think is
going to happen
and you bring that into your next
marriage
forget about the next marriage do even
people get married anymore people don't
get married more as you said right
there's like toys and i mean
i was looking the other day uh this ad
popped up it's like now you can just get
a robot woman
you know what i mean and for the women
you got all types of toys and whatnot so
actually people don't even want to get
married anymore they start just
exploring these weird stuff and always
just leads you into
another level i got this i got this dm
one day on the t3 on instagram
we get we got some interesting dms bro
i'll say the least i'm sure you do too
and it was uh
what do i do every time i'm having
intercourse with my wife
and it's missionary she always uses the
vibrator
on her clitoris
while i'm penetrating and if i'm just
penetrating it's not enough she
literally tells me to stop
she goes to get that vibrator uses it
and then she can
and he's like bro i just feel so
emasculated i just feel like so just
under you know like i'm not doing it for
her anymore and she needs this and and
and then he's having anxiety bro because
her her toys are bigger than him bro no
doubt and and how do you i keep saying
to brothers like brothers yeah same type
of stuff comes up
women ask things brothers ask things you
know there's
how do you compete with the energizer
bunny with with with with what's what's
what kind of batteries we have energized
duracell yeah and you know just those
vibrations alone
if you look at the
the what do you call the oscillation
uh
of the vibe we cannot compete with that
yeah but why you even get to that point
because once you go there you think
you're gonna want to come back to just
but if she doesn't know that
she's just used to what you have
right but then again the guy maybe he
didn't do his best and what he's
supposed to do i dm'd him bro i was like
what how did it even get to this he's
just like oh it's always been like this
yeah because again
i mean we're getting into another topic
but we gotta wrap this one up but really
quick man it's because again going back
to the history
a lot of women cannot climax from the
inside because they condition themselves
through masturbation to climax from the
outside imagine you're spending 10 years
and yes women masturbate and yes women
watch porn and yes there's a lot more
going in the female body than the male
by the guy is like kind of like it's
very simple man
talk two minutes he's out
right for the woman is a bit more takes
more time more conditioning the brain
changes when you are doing that there's
an association between that movement and
what you're stimulating that one organ
the clitoris that's just designed for
pleasure with the brain that's what
you're used to and all of a sudden you
get this guy who wants to do something
different
why a lot of women would not be used to
the inside is because they're scared of
losing the virginity of breaking
things and you know having issues once
they get married so there's not going to
be any internal stimulation usually
other than very basic so they it's much
easier faster sometimes more pleasurable
to just stimulate the outside
right the inside is a whole different
story we can go into the anatomy and the
you know the the sexual part of it in
another episode
but a lot of times that's why women now
want that plus i'll tell you that that's
not the first time she's experienced
that that bullet or whatever it's called
it's she's been doing that for some time
so she wants what she's familiar with
and what she's conditioned herself to
climax with and it's not enough and
that's why i said see if you pass the
limits bro there's no return trust me
there's no return yeah the ground
there's no none of that allowed for that
brother i would tell him
learn how to use your tongue
learn how to use your fingers
and then once you got that game down
unlocked learn how to do dry orgasms
and then
when she says oh emmy they hand me the
the toy
say now there we go
it's going to take it's easier said than
done bro like you got it it's going to
take time bro it's going to take bro it
shouldn't be you shouldn't reach that
level yeah and then the thing is
but the reality is at that level for a
long time before but that's the thing
the man don't understand the female
sexual why does she need that extra
stimulation because she's not ready
so there's a psychosomatic relationship
between like the brain is related he
said she used to be like this when they
met no doubt and that's what i'm saying
so see
again we said what's the most powerful
organ for a woman when it comes to sex
with your mind you need to work that
mind before anything because when you
work the mind
and you make him love and you prepare
she's already at that close to the
threshold
and it's long before the bedroom right
it's right so once she's close with just
penetration is basic stimulation even if
you're using your hand or whatever is
going to take her to that level
but if she's not even she's like down
here then that's why she needs the extra
support and he's just sitting there
doing something there's
i would also say there's no more passion
in making love it's just like
okay bring the toy
what do you mean bring the toy because
there's no heat there's no passion
there's no more love it's
i don't know you look at these just
what's out there it's just like yo let's
smash it's like there's no build up
there's no connection because it's more
than just intercourse it's more than
just stimulating the the clitoris man
it's like a full body you know
experience where to
you know connect and if you're not
building to that
that love that passion the kissing the
touching is gonna bring her to that
level man you just gotta do a little
literally bro a woman within two three
minutes can go
explode you know what i'm saying
but if not you're gonna take about 20
minutes of that toy or whatever weird
stuff and whatnot if and it's forced
it's a forced climax i'm telling you a
lot of these toys is just i need to get
off it's force you're not really having
that full experience that's coming from
that really good sex you know what i
mean it's just a force let me just get
off it's literally called the rabbit you
know you get off yeah i get off and then
we're good to go
you haven't really experienced love
making if it's like that so for me as
rule man i mean i don't know people i've
read some books from ole miss
from was studying from this time they
said look some toys are permissible i
believe it's not 100 zero do not allow
that
slope you know with time maybe she can
really re rewire her brain and get back
to i would say so six months maybe one
year slowly your body gets used to you
haven't been you know experienced that
but
zero policy bro zero tolerance man well
this is what goes back to what i said
that as a man we have to be the ones
that are leading everything because like
you said as men you know we can
stimulate women we there's a foreplay
before the foreplay no doubt right now
if the foreplay before the foreplay is a
real thing which
we know yes it's a real thing the real
thing man a story that i can bring in
here from
a friend that i used to know back in the
four days
was uh
he had met this girl
and she was using
drugs and stuff and
he basically when he saw it he told her
to just throw it out yeah he didn't say
anything else you just he said throw it
out get rid of that and then she said
why he's like because you have me you
don't need that and then from that
moment on she threw it out and he
continued to stimulate her mind before
anything else and that's it she never
needed it again you never need it again
bro
that's it
that's powerful bro
i think with that being said inshallah
let us know what you guys thought about
this episode
and ramyan
for tuning in and with that being said
we have about 20 minutes left so let's
just talk about that let's get into like
yeah i don't know let's just let's just
make this uh like the taboo on intimacy
or something because there's no bro we
spent like 60 70 percent of the time
so what do you want we don't even get
into it let's just stick on this topic
bro like how like the taboo on intimacy
and all this yeah yeah and we can get
into it there's no way you're watching
you guys have to give me questions start
there's no way it's just myself do you
mind if we interrupt you please because
i mean i don't know where to go anymore
if
[Laughter]
yeah so all this being said this
disclaimer being said right
bro i don't i don't even know your pause
there's no way bro let's just let's do
the vibe because i have a question
this guy like
if you have lactose intolerance and you
got anal leakage by all means
make sure to pick yourself up a bottle
of lactate you are gay you are
transgender
come on bro okay okay
back back on the topic you're finished
[Music]
um
[Music]